WHEN WE ARRIVED,
WE MET OUR SPACE FAMILY--
THE THREE OTHER HUMANS
WHO WOULD JOIN US
ON OUR HEAVENLY JOURNEY.
THERE WAS BRYCE FROOD,
WHO TOLD ME SECRETLY
HE PLANNED TO PROPOSE
TO HIS GIRLFRIEND, CARRIE,
AT 300,00 FEET,
AND THE SINGER AND CERTIFIED
COSMONAUT LANCE BASS,
WHO HAD RAISED FUNDS
FOR HIS TRIP
THROUGH AN AMBITIOUS
SPONSORSHIP PLAN.
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE.
- RIGHT?
- WERE WE ALL SUPPOSED
TO DO THAT?
- I WISH I HAD THOUGHT OF THAT.
- YEAH.
- WE'RE GONNA BE LEAVING
THIS PLACE, EARTH.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
ANYWHERE NEAR THESE PLANETOIDS
OR ANY PLANETOIDS,
FOR THAT MATTER.
WE'RE GONNA BE STAYING
RIGHT IN HERE.
- WHAT WILL WE
BE LOOKING DOWN ON?
OVER ONE THRILLING WEEK,
THE FIVE OF US
COMPLETED AN EXHAUSTIVE SERIES
OF PREPARATIONS.
- FLOCK OF SEAGULLS.
- WE SIGNED OUR LIFE AWAY
ON NUMEROUS FORMS.
- EVERYBODY GETS ONE.
- WE LEARNED
SPECIAL SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
- ONE, TWO, THREE.
VERY GOOD.
- YOU KNOW, SOMEDAY
WE'RE GONNA LIVE IN OUTER SPACE
AND LIVE ON PLANETS.
I WON'T BE AROUND TO SEE THAT,
AND I DON'T THINK I WANT TO,
BUT JUST TO READ ABOUT IT
IS SO EXCITING.
- NOW HIT
THAT THREE-POINT SAFETY CHECK.
- WHAT?
- THE THREE-POINT--
- YES, THEY ARE
ONE, TWO, THREE,
AND OUT YOUR GO.
- OKAY.
GREAT. YEAH.
- GOOD JOB.
- THEN WE SPENT A DAY JUMPING
ON TRAMPOLINES
TO PREPARE OUR BODIES AND MINDS
FOR ZERO GRAVITY.
- AND STRATOJUMP.
GOOD.
TOUCH YOUR TOES, SIR.
- IT WAS THE FINAL STAGE
OF PREPARATION WE NEEDED
FOR THE RIGORS OF SPACE TRAVEL.